yo guys I'm Ryan right I'm Lauren gah
and we're gonna watch the trailer for
snowpiercer no beer sir you know what
it's about Lauren it's about snowmen
that go get their ears pierced well I'm
excited to watch it says radar for
violence language to drug cons about to
go down okay so this is a red band
trailer uncensored let's do this you're
playing yeah it's like Chris have AIDS
that's because that men yeah to shoulder
now all the strength to pierce it there
is one thing it's called order ha ha
he's the valiant the whole zone
all things in Lansing like 0o hasn't
just in this section
each of our three or a particular
position
please [ __ ] weird I the first
belong to the table no looks like the
hunger kids yeah yeah 74% of you shall
die this is going to good
what the [ __ ]
like everybody a one
pretty good my violin
ah
ah
we control the engine through the
controller
I did not see one snowman yeah I'm very
disappointed what the [ __ ] Hollywood the
most misleading title in the world
actually looks pretty cool okay so that
it looks like Hunger Games on a train
but instead of having two tributes from
every district they just put everybody
in train guards and kill each other yeah
it's like a rated R version of The
Hunger Games I'm excited for that man I
just love a good violent movie and Chris
Evans excited to see him doing an
r-rated flick that's awesome man I like
him he's pretty good-looking man he is a
good-looking man if you're new to the
channel so subscribe people subscribe
you know you can put like buttons
everywhere where I put my hands right
now you're making my life so agonizing
that if he doesn't actually do that then
everybody comment mean things Wow
people already come and mean things when
they ask for a shout-out can only
imagine they're like my little raver
whole family yeah I've had people make
rape comments before you out throughout
we're gonna do some shout outs we're
gonna do some shout outs raymond
fernandes
name on the fernandes like a beast why
are you being racist again what do you
mean I'm not being racist I'm just you
did it in an accent if it's
complimentary you know it might be okay
but maybe it's not maybe Raymond is
offended by that but Everybody Loves
Raymond har-har-har [ __ ] I bet you never
got that man I bet I was the first one
to come up with that right here right
now [ __ ] better than his name is
Everybody Loves Raymond versus everyone
hates Chris yeah exactly
and every Chris I hate now because that
damn show that stupid show that's stupid
show ruined everything
sorry Chris is out there but Raymond
everyone loves you including Lorene I
love you stop in the name of Allah stop
right now
Thank You Spice Girls no no no I don't
know that song if you want to be my
lover you gotta get with my friends make
it nothi
the answer despair should never end I'm
the father girl in a Barbie world and
last elastic what what's wrong we and my
mom Bobby let's go party ah-ah-ah-yeah
come on barbie let's go party come on
Barbie let's go party yeah come on Bobby
let's go party oh okay I'm having so
much fun
well Bobby we're just getting started we
should go karaoke we should don't really
do karaoke that'd be a lot of fun GF
mystery solver 1 2 3 gif my old friend
mystery solving the mystery of
girlfriends in general or how to get a
girlfriend or how to get a girlfriend
which apparently the huge ministry to
riot it's it's the biggest mystery to me
actually I never know how GF mystery
solver 1 2 or 3
dude you better give me advice some
really good advice please with cherries
on top oh come on man I'll suck your
dick if that's what it takes
oh I've never actually sucked a dick see
maybe you have to try it both ways I
don't know man the thought of a penis
being in my mouth just does not boast
well for me now you know how do you feel
if you're what really all women feel
that way some women love it right
they're all lying
there's like a penis in your mouth
you know what pee comes out of that what
about if a guy eats you out that's not
my problem problem like pees it coming
out of that Opie comes out of your
vagina right no we're gonna burn a hole
for that what if you accidentally touch
that hole but also women wipe after they
pee and then do not biota Li well you
like it yeah
few strokes little jiggle and then two
strokes that's how you do it man you
learn how I clean up after I pee
I'm sure it's talks like this why don't
get girlfriends yeah Alex Bernal Alex
Bernal wanted a shout out so yeah what's
up you get a song
- shout out when you gonna rhyme it that
sounds it in hatchery the melody with it
yeah dude you're a fan of the channel
and I appreciate having you as one of
our fans thanks Alex seriously Alex you
go out there and you go pursue your
dreams Alex I want you to be someone
special don't let me down don't crack
under the pressure guys you gotta learn
to persist gonna persist yeah do it just
you know you ever fall back down just
look up cuz you can get up
Richmond why does it reach for the moon
because you might end up among the stars
reach for the stars cuz you might land
on the moon Alex I notice the stars I'm
sure are further than the moon why would
someone reach for the moon and then land
on the Stars I did say I wasn't sure how
the saying went so you Chinese women are
supposed to be smart sorry ow
second most sex I've ever had yeah I
believe him yeah look how pretty she is
when she does that face yeah yeah I bet
when someone goes down on you that's the
face you make oh yeah ever guys make a
weird